well democracy has had a bit of a tough
time obviously with her in the room in
the room I don't want to go into too
much detail but we know how they both
did in recent elections disastrously and
that's being favorable that's why I was
so drawn to the idea from the
Conservatives in the Queen's speech to
introduce compulsory photo ID for voters
such as a passport or driving license in
future elections given the number of
proven cases of electoral fraud is
vanishingly thin but by its very nature
you're unlikely to ever get a true grip
on the size of the problem now it's only
a few years ago that a mayor was booted
from office in East London and the poll
declared void due to wholesale fraud now
it is time this was brought in along
with a full review of the postal voting
system which has the look of being as
genuine as a ruling from Speaker John
burka opponents cry its vote rigging but
that's just baseless can I count on your
vote you certainly cannot count on my
own words against you you said democracy
has had a bit of a hard time of late and
proven cases of voter fraud are
vanishing these things so there is no
point in this kind of legislation and
actually the thing that concerns me as
is always a case with this kind of these
sorts of policies it's the most
vulnerable and the most underrepresented
groups are worse hid so in July 2018 20
charities came together to warn against
this kind of legislation from the
Salvation Army
a UK Liberty centre point because if you
look at it at the at the moment 11
million people in the UK do not have a
driving license or a passport often they
are the poorest in society and if we are
living in an era where we're trying to
encourage more people to vote right
why would we want to make it harder but
all I would say to that and it's a very
valid point and it was something that
worried me but you may or may not be
aware it is a requirement in Northern
Ireland if you don't have a driver's
license
you don't have a passport it is the
local authorities to provide you with to
provide you at no cost no cost with a
car no but the point is what idea you
going to have to produce to actually
qualify that they haven't told us what
you're going to have to produce a
qualify for that card
you don't worry this may be the first
step towards compulsory ID cards are you
worried about I don't want to be in a
situation where a police officer and
just stop you coming out of the corner
shop and say can I see your ID what I'm
concerned say in the u.s. they've had
this experience with it is correct that
the most vulnerable people in society
don't have the necessary identification
giving you the car your NHS card there
is the more in admin and paperwork you
introduce whether it's getting a card
from the center so you're not worried
about electoral fraud no the answer is I
would be worried if it existed and I'm
wondering where exists in the numbers
that make a difference - okay so I'm not
opposed to compulsory ID cards I
actually think they're a good idea and I
would be in favor of having those in the
first place so that's the first point
with that in mind I've always thought
it's very peculiar that you don't need
any form of ID to vote I need ID if I
want to buy cigarettes if I want to buy
alcohol if I if I need to go to a
library often I need to take a live look
so young I can buy booze anytime is we
have ID requirements are very simplistic
things in our society but something as
monumental as determining who rules the
society we don't have them so I was
being favored but my question to you and
probably when we're talking about
vanishingly small it was 20 a
allegations of a
fraud in 2007 17 with only one
conviction so that's the number but my
question to you would be my question to
you would be Nick when I think about
where the opportunities for voter fraud
is I think often about postal fraud
postal votes yes with photographic ID no
that won't be that's a separate side
we're finally poised it is - - we turn
for the penalty decider Rachel Johnson
you will determine the outcome of this
debate
I started off agreeing with you but
you've lost me I think one of the things
I love about living in this country is
the fact that you can walk into a
village hall or a school on a Thursday
and a lady or a man at a desk will
accept you for who you are how about an
you can vote you have a you don't even
have to bring your polling card because
it will disadvantage I don't often quote
this man but I would like to bring in a
clip of Jeremy Corbyn because I think
he's actually right on this we will not
allow this government to stifle
democracy by making it harder for people
to vote there are huge risks in the
legislation being proposed which will
disproportionately affect working class
minority and young voters see lot even a
stop clock is right twice more bring it
in from peace to vote as well things
like absolute but you didn't target my
respond to my keep which is the
opportunity for real fraud is I mean
it's a separate conversation but I'm
happy to go down that route I do think
there are concerns and indeed if you
research there are concerns about postal
voting there does appear that in some
instances you almost have like that the
master of the house if you will decides
to vote for or they've been suggestions
that someone has collected all the
voting cards for an elderly or a time at
home it's called a retirement home and
you've suddenly got twenty five